par cartes seulement le rêve de 24
heures dans les ptt contre le projet de
déréglementation des télécommunications
plusieurs manifestations aujourd'hui à
paris dix mille personnes selon la cgt
pour la marche sur le ministère 2000
d'après les chiffres officiels qui
donnent entre 12 et 19 % de grévistes
mobilisation très forte dans les
télécoms annonce la cgt jusqu'à 50%
cette femme et la mère de georges
ibrahim abdallah le chef présumé des
forces armées révolutionnaires
libanaises
madame abdallah a pu rendre visite à son
fils abdallah purge une peine de
réclusion à perpétuité à la centrale de
saint maur dans l'indre madame à dallas
n'a fait aucune déclaration son fils est
en bonne santé ont déclaré ses avocats
d'affaires grégory au palais de justice
de dijon qu'estime vilma devant le juge
simon aujourd'hui et demain pour un
complément d'information demandée en
juin dernier les époux villemin confie
aujourd'hui au juge d'instruction du
tribunal
une information judiciaire contre x au
complicité d'assassinats à l'être